aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ayer decías algo sobre las creencias no
puede escucharte estaba con el corazón
puesto en las cortaderas al costado de
la ruta encendidas por el sol
crepuscular y por el viento utilizándose
con ellas mi pelo en el mismo gesto de
ofrecer a la luz materia para su reflejo
dejándome tocar porque estaba ahí en
comunión con el momento y no es que no
pueda pensar te juro que entiendo las
grandes dudas pero el instante de
certeza efímera estoy viva y me muevo
con la vida fue lo primero
le digo que si a la poesía le digo que
sí y digo que es como el amor te pasa y
no salís igual el asunto es que nadie
sabe cómo va a salir a cada cual le pasa
de una manera misteriosa no hay una
clave para entender esa manera además
perdería el encanto por eso la poesía
como el amor no es para unos pocos
elegidos está ahí para el que la quiera
es gratis y de efecto a largo plazo
para empezar la poesía es un estado del
cuerpo
como un escalofrío como un enamoramiento
es como si uno entrara en otra dimensión
el tiempo se detuviera los sentidos se
expandieran y los sonidos de las
palabras el ritmo la respiración nos
conectarán muy profundamente con algo
dentro de nosotros mismos
nadie te puede decir de quién enamorarte
ni cómo va a suceder
pero algo es indispensable
hay que estar dispuesto hay que dejar
que suceda en algún momento hay que
levantar los ojos para encontrarse con
otra mirada y que el cuerpo se conoció
ne
con la poesía es igual
por eso me parece una pena que
muchísimas personas se pierdan de la
experiencia solo por pensar que no es
para ellas
cummins el poeta escribió
el amor es un sitio y a través de ese
sitio del amor se mueven con brillo de
sosiego todos los sitios el sí es un
mundo y en este mundo del sí viven
cuidadosamente humillados todos los
mundos
entonces le digo que sí a la poesía
si a dejarla entrar al cuerpo que por
otro lado está hecho de poesía aunque no
lo sepa la poesía está presente en el
modo en que alguien se ilumina cuando ve
a la persona que le gusta en la manera
en que sale una carcajada
así falta entender porque ese dibujo
sonoro en el aire tiene el efecto
transformador y contagioso que tiene
es una evidencia la poesía está en el
arco entre un paso y otro en los
parpadeos en el silencio del asombro
porque el cuerpo es ritmo hay que
prestarle atención nada más así lo
poético es ese vínculo primitivo gestual
intenso con los demás que pueden ser
cosas palabras o una persona
el enojo por las injusticias el
desamparo las preguntas existenciales
pueden encontrar
modos poéticos metáforas inesperadas
formas sorpresivas como las que eligió
elizabeth bishop para escribir su poema
un arte
el arte de perder' se domina fácilmente
tantas cosas parecen decididas a
extraviarse que su pérdida no es ningún
desastre
perder algo cada día aceptar la angustia
de las llaves perdidas de las horas
derrochadas en vano el arte de perder se
domina fácilmente
después entrena ten perder más lejos en
perder más rápido lugares sin hombres
los sitios en los que pensaban viajar
ninguna de esas pérdidas ocasionará al
desastre perdí el reloj de mi madre y
mira se me fue la última o la penúltima
de mis tres casas amadas
el arte de perder' se domina fácilmente
perdí dos ciudades dos hermosas ciudades
y aún más
algunos reinos que tenía dos ríos un
continente
los extraño pero no fue un desastre
incluso al perderte la voz bromista el
gesto que amo no habré mentido
es indudable que el arte de perder' se
domina fácilmente aunque parezca
escribirlo un desastre
eso que cuando lees o escuchas queda
reverberando adentro tuyo por extraño y
preciso eso que vuelve una y otra vez si
no sabes cómo eso es materia poética
trabajando y lo único que hay que hacer
es entregarse con confianza aunque uno
no entienda atender cómo crecen las
palabras adentro del cuerpo
me acuerdo de una sensación
cuando era chica me gustaba despertarme
y mirar el baile que hacían las
partículas suspendidas en los rayos de
luz que entraban por los huequitos de
las persianas
quieta y muda para que no me
interrumpieran
ese momento era como entrar a un lugar
sagrado lo que a simple vista parecía
invisible aire vacío de pronto se
revelaba como una galaxia y los millones
de puntos eran planetas conectados en
sus atmósferas envolventes en armonías
con un universo nuevo y secreto
me parece que la poesía puede ser
ese as de luz que revela lo que a simple
vista no se ve
[Aplausos]
la nueva táctica es decir que si una
prueba para ver cuánto dura la táctica
si por ejemplo al invierno en un lugar
caluroso si a las pesadillas y a los
fuegos artificiales al amanecer si a los
semáforos al smog a las montañas a la
neblina y a los barrenderos con sus
escobillones que todavía aparecen
árboles si al ciego que toque el banjo
si a los bancos y a la ceguera si a los
brillos a los que se comen con picantes
a los que se escuchan de noche si a la
pelea a la forma en que explota como un
cohete en el desfile si a la
transpiración al hombre que me pregunto
de qué parte de españa era por qué no
entonces si si a la chica que está
perdiendo todo el pelo a la sangre al
granizo al cachorro que le enseña la luz
en el suelo buscar la pelota le digo sí
mira si para sí sí a la rápida muerte
del día de hoy a los tamales a la
traducción en los policías que juegan a
la pelota en el patio de la iglesia sí
sí al dolor o al menos a lo que se saca
del aljibe y se acarrea casa en el balde
si al no de nunca es suficiente si me
voy a arrepentir si a la fuente el
pececito invisible del chico de 6 años a
las palabras y a los puños a los besos
en la puerta al que estás
haciendo vos acá al y albos y al
acá del sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y